what will a billion dollars get you an
island rata caucuses in American Samoa
yeah they have 100% reported and Mike
Bloomberg gets five delegates from
American Samoa yes congratulations
bloomer you earned it
but what a price tag his campaign is the
political version of movie popcorn
bloomers spent enough to feed nearly
everyone in the city of South Bend
Indiana mayor Pete's hometown for two
years millions per delegate all to
convince people he was better than Trump
if you see some portly dude with a
toupee buying everyone at the bar drinks
you can bet he's a campaign consultant
Bloomberg's loss is his new Porshe
but lessons abound bloomie proved money
talks considering his drab persona his
cash still got him nearly to the front
of the line who knows if he had skipped
that debate that's the other lesson
money can buy you votes but not a
personality ultimately you're still
stuck with this
I really am surprised that all of these
my fellow contestants up here I guess
would be the right word for it
given nobody pays attention to the clock
I'm surprised they show up because I
would have thought after I did such a
good job in beating them last week that
they'd be a little bit afraid to do that
they talked about 40 Democrats 21 of
those with people that I spent a hundred
million dollars to help elect I got them
we have a very few non-disclosure
agreements how many how many
none of them accused me of doing
anything other than maybe they didn't
like the joke I told all right and let's
not forget let's not forget his unique
way of eating pizza licking each finger
I haven't been this grossed out since I
walked in on my grandpa then there's Liz
who couldn't even win her own state
that's like your family going on
vacation without you she's Macaulay
Culkin and home alone the entire state
ditched her leaving her with one powwow
cookbook and 365 identical black shirts
the lesson here America is pretty good
with discerning fakes Liz couldn't shake
the authentic truth that our ambition
created new deceptions and each lie a
new twist on victimhood no wonder her
constituents had reserved
patience for a woman who falsely claimed
her ancestors lived on one so last night
the Dems chose a comfy sweater over
identity politics money and a socialist
could the party finally have grown up no
all they did was reach old age no one
what sucks about him dropping out is
we're not gonna see the Bloomberg Trump
match up we'd so desperately wanted
because it would be great it would have
been interesting right you know because
we live in a populist age as we often
talk about and we think hum you know
what maybe Sanders is the mirror of
Trump but actually Bloomberg would have
been an interesting mirror to Trump I
don't know if the populist base of the
Democratic Party would have taken to him
the way the populist base of the GOP
took to Trump but I will say you know to
me in looking back on Bloomberg's
campaign now no one can defy the primary
process he's decided to skip those first
four first four contests like Giuliani
yeah like Rudy that's what I can't Kurt
to me they like Rudy Kennedy and
obviously didn't work for Rudy and it
didn't work for him maybe somebody in
the future is able to do it again with a
lot of money but it didn't work for this
game you know Kennedy I was just
thinking when I was doing this that Liz
was really the one that took out blue
Berg yes she pulled the Kerrigan as I
like to call it though Liz and and I
think she's really going to hurt herself
with progressives if she stays in
because she was there for two reasons
and and both of those reasons were to
protect Joe Biden so she has promised
her her allegiance to the Democratic
establishment from the beginning of this
process because she has needed their
support and and she stayed in in order
to poke a few more holes in Bloomberg
not that that needed to happen after
last night but also to take some votes
away from Bernie so you know how would
Bernie have done in Massachusetts if she
had dropped out before Super Tuesday and
you know it's pretty clear that he would
have had a greater delegate Hall if she
had and I'm just wondering you know
Ilhan Omar sent out a nasty tweet last
night and squarely at Elizabeth Warren
and I'm wondering if she shares that
vitriol with more progressives who
really now want nothing to do with her
oh brother
as I like to say hey Jesse almost forgot
your name Jesse Watters yes
I want to know what you're thinking now
about Bloomberg or Liz I'm thinking it
with you by an island you should get to
live there this has to be the biggest
con job of all time did you all see now
that Bloomberg
campaign had seven fully paid staffers
living in America Samoa for three months
Sealy I have to see that expense report
I know junkets and that has got to be
the best junket of all time there are
40,000 voters in America Samoa mm-hmm
they only got a hundred and seventy five
of them to vote for Mike Bloomberg what
the hell were they doing in American
Samoa
about three months partying it's amazing
and Bloomberg didn't even miss that he
was missing a half a billion this has to
be a huge con job you get 7% of the ad
buy he spent over five hundred million
dollars the ad guy I'm not gonna say his
name made 40 million dollars this winter
mmm I'm not gonna say his name is gonna
hate you no ex-girlfriends or pretend
family members knocking at his door with
their hands out because everybody knew
this guy did not have the political
talent to pull this off he can't read a
prompter he's worse than Al Sharpton his
voice is worse than Liz Warren and he
looks like a sea turtle
he actually said this I was watching a
speech last night yeah this is words
that he said ready he read this I want
to put the United back in the United
States of America even baito or work
would have crossed that line is not good
material Katie do care to add anything
on him we're never going to solve the
Box controversy whether Michael
Bloomberg it's a box of people to debate
President Trump but there everyone's
making a pretty big deal out of the fact
that Michael Bloomberg is backing Joe
Biden and it's like congratulations the
guy who won 175 votes in American Samoa
is now backing you and endorsing you
good luck like maybe some of the money
will be helpful by in terms of a
movement any kind of grassroots support
from Michael Bloomberg it doesn't exist
so I wouldn't be banking on that the
other thing is Michael Bloomberg
participating in that debate in the Town
Hall with Fox he completely exposed
himself as
an elitist who believes that he knows
better than you and that he's going to
tell you how you're supposed to live
your life well he gets to do whatever he
wants he used to be kind of this figure
that nobody really had like a moderate
appeal to I think he completely exposed
himself as the opposite and no
self-awareness licking his fingers
putting that happy oh my god it's back
in the box Super Tuesday I think a
champagne finger looking video didn't
you vote for him as a Republican I
wasn't living in New York City at the
time but nice try one okay I have a dump
we gotta go on but what a stupid
question you can laugh at me American
Samoa is there another Samoa
it's a conglomeration of islands there
you go it's it's totally should home the
mini mics
right